you do have a little bit of say in the
matter you know it depends who need
receivers but you know um
i definitely you know the pittsburgh
steelers big ben is definitely good with
the b-ball
and you know um the indianapolis coats
you know the way they used ty hilton and
and when we played those guys in the
playoffs last year and i walked off and
i'm like you know like this this team is
you know they they up and coming
you know they they gonna be a problem in
the next few years so
you know i got i got options you know
like i feel like i would fit in anywhere
but you know like that was just the main
two off top and you know anyway i can
come in and help
and be like a small piece to the puzzle
or if they need me to be a big piece to
come in and help younger girls out and
you know
move around and do what i have to do so
those like yeah those are the main two
teams though
that's john brown formerly the buffalo
bills on sirius xm nfl radio who also
said that he had no idea the bills were
going to let him go they didn't talk to
him about taking less they didn't talk
about anything they just dumped them he
he wonders whether to what extent josh
allen had input because he believes in
that josh allen would have wanted him to
stay but he's out he's interested in the
steelers or the cults steelers have a
great young core of receivers they do a
great job drafting receivers i don't
know that he fits there the cults he
mentioned ty hilton hilton may be gone
in free agency but it's one thing for a
guy to say here's who i want in this
year especially what ultimately matters
is who wants you and he may have to sit
and wait and and it comes down to this
question
one year deal
do you join a team that you think's a
contender do you just take what you can
get you know the bad teams are going to
need players too
but a lot of guys are going to be doing
i believe miles one-year contracts this
year taking what they can get and hoping
to have the kind of impact that they can
get more
in 2022
yeah and i don't know what john brown's
market is going to be especially to join
a good team although frankly the wide
receivers who are available right now
in terms of free agency it's not
really all that great i mean our top two
guys on the pft 100 list i believe are
kenny goliday and then juju smith
schuster and then after that it's kind
of like
so i think that brown could maybe get a
team but if i'm a team i might just say
let me wait until after the draft in
order to see if i really want to sign a
wide receiver who is not named juju
smith schuster or kenny galladay because
maybe i can get somebody better in the
draft and if that happens then they're
probably going to be cheaper at least
for this year and then i can develop
that guy and maybe they're going to be
even better down the road so i don't
really know what his market's going to
be he had a decent year last year he had
over a thousand yards in 2019 um then of
course you know when buffalo gets steph
on diggs then and he sets all kinds of
franchise records and leads the league
in all those different categories then
that's going to be the primary target so
yeah i don't really know what his
market's gonna be mike
well gabriel davis also his development
as a rookie last year he made some great
catches in big spots and i think that it
gave them the confidence they can go
forward with someone younger and cheaper
and that's the key and you make a good
point teams may wait to see what happens
in the draft and that's going to be the
the challenge when do you make your move
as a free agent the windows open here's
an opportunity is it going to be a
better opportunity if i wait or is it
going to be a worse opportunity some
guys as shereen williams has suggested
they sit out the whole season some guys
may wait until the regular season starts
they avoid training camp that way some
guys you know you just sit and wait for
the phone to ring during the season
there may be some veteran replacement
available that wouldn't otherwise be
available once we get into september
october november etcetera juju's miss
schuster likely will be signing
somewhere next week it likely won't be
the steelers even though he has said he
wants to stay with the steelers he wants
his legacy to be in pittsburgh
it's fairly obvious the steelers are
going to move on for whatever it is he's
going to command miles they have too
many young guys who are making far less
setting aside dancing on the logos of
the opponents and the browns is the
browns the kind of misguided antics that
didn't help the steelers at all last
year he's a great player
but
dollar for dollar
they're gonna be better off i think with
someone else so juju on social media
hinting that he won't be back
there's his
item apparently oh he voted no
on
will he stay in pittsburgh he actually
voted no
voted that's a negative so
it's yeah i think it's pretty clear juju
won't be back with the pittsburgh
steelers uh the raiders were linked to
him a few weeks back
miles i don't know where it's gonna go
but i think what we do know is the team
mvp from 2018 that moment that ended the
relationship between the steelers and
antonio brown he's going to be gone too
yeah i think the steelers just do too
good of a job of drafting and developing
wide receivers to ever sign one you know
when they could let that guy go and then
they get a comp pick for him back the
next year it just makes way too much
sense for juju smith schuster to sign
somewhere else but i think if you look
at what he does i have questions about
whether he's a number one guy or not i
think if he's in a situation where he
can be the number two he's probably
going to be better off and if you're
talking about the raiders well
if he goes there and when they got rugs
they got edwards i mean they prob the
raiders i think would be much better off
signing nelson aguilar for another year
at least than maybe going with somebody
who doesn't know that offense and you've
got juju smith schuster and you're
counting on him to be the lead dog i
have questions as to whether he's really
going to be able to do that because i
don't know
that when he kind of had the opportunity
to do so in pittsburgh that it really
really worked out to the way that one
would expect based on the way those
early returns were so i think if juju
juice and the shuster can go somewhere
and be a number two guy and supplement
somebody else he can really make an
offense better i don't know if you
really want to count on that guy as the
number one and maybe this will be on
freezing cold takes in another year
no we saw it in 2019 though miles when
antonio brown was traded juju's miss
schuster was not able to step into that
number one role and i remember vividly
quotes from him suggesting he's doing
what he can to draw double coverage down
the field and run the deep routes if you
don't have the god-given ability baked
in to your skill set to run really fast
and pull that coverage with you you
can't be a number one and so then here's
the question
if you're number two
how much can you really pay a number two
because unless you have a number one
who's on a rookie contract and making a
hell of a lot less
than your number two
you're gonna be paying a ton of money to
your top two receivers now the
buccaneers apparently comfortable doing
that this year with mike evans and chris
godwin but most teams aren't going to be
in a position to make a major financial
investment in their number two
especially with so many great young
receivers out there that you can draft
so
i i think there's a chance juju is not
going to get you know 12 14 million a
year again schedule you have to be in a
spot and maybe the raiders make the most
sense because they have henry ruggs
who's got two more years under contract
before they can even give him an
extension that's the perfect spot to be
a number two with a rookie or a guy on a
rookie deal that can't be renegotiated
yet because if henry ruggs gets salty
because juju smith schuster's there
making so much more than rugs all the
raiders have to say is but not we can do
we we'd love to give you more money we
will when we can but we can't so just go
play and earn your second contract like
juju smith schuster did
yeah but what evidence have you seen
that even though ruggs was the first
wide receiver off the board in that
really really talented class in 2012 i
forgot you hit i forgot you hate i
forgot i forgot you hate henry ruggs
why do you hate henry ruggs i'm just
going by the production mike i can only
go by what i saw what did henry rugs do
besides catch that bomb off of greg
williams inc
ridiculous zero blitz
i i don't know he had he didn't even
have 500 yards receiving man as you know
i i just he's got all he's got
production and that's what i think what
can i say
he's got the speed to be a number one
that's you have to have that speeder you
got no chance of being a number one i
agree he's got more to do i look look at
it this way a better example
the vikings aren't going to move on from
adam thielen but
if they didn't have adam thielen
that's an example of where you could
justify paying juju to be the number two
and there's nothing justin jefferson can
say about it is that are you you don't
hate justin jefferson do you yeah
actually no i think that that's actually
a very good example and it's one i was
going to bring up if you hadn't asked me
about henry ruggs directly so
that yes because the vikings do make a
lot of sense because obviously what they
did in shipping off uh in shipping off
diggs stefan diggs i wanted to call him
quandre that's his brother um but when
they shipped him off
they were able to then say okay we're
gonna use this first round pick to get
another wide receiver and then we have a
cheap guy that we can place next to
somebody that we already have and
feeling and it worked out extremely well
so yeah i think in that situation yeah
when you're talking about number ones
and number twos and free agency and all
that that would make more sense but at
this point i just i don't know i don't
the raiders don't have a one wide
receiver and maybe if you have agalor
and then you pair him with shuster and
then you have rugs as another speed guy
and that gives you more weapons that
makes more sense to me i don't know mike
i i'm looking at adam thielen's contract
11.1 million base salary this year
i mean if you're the vikings do you
think we could get juju
and and and this is the pro this is what
teams gonna have to go through because
adam feeling great story local guy
mankato state minnesota through and
through
is is dollar for dollar you put juju
with justin jefferson versus thielen but
these are the analyses that teams are
going to have to engage in this year
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports